[Music]
good morning everyone great to see you
all thank you uh for everyone for
organizing it's really been wonderful uh
being here in a wonderful meeting
so i'll talk today about a lot of the
efforts in my lab where you know i sort
of think about my lab as having this one
very big overarching goal that we
may never achieve but we will try is to
try to make
identifying some of the genetic
mechanisms of human disease
a routine event you know these are it's
it's certainly very hard and slow to do
and um and so our goals involve pushing
technologies forward pushing thinking
forward thinking about where the
challenges are that we can try to
overcome to start to make this something
that happens more kind of as an everyday
um event and so you know i'll start
today i'm going to talk about a couple
case studies um
one's an old example that we've studied
for a while i won't talk about the tools
has been pretty well published then i'll
talk about um some new work that's
that's largely unpublished and then i'll
sort of go in a little bit on some of
the things that we're thinking about and
how we can build some of the the paths
that we can learn from case studies into
kind of highways of mass transit so
in terms of some of the past that i'll
talk about today i'll first highlight
some examples from common complex
diseases again studies that we published
several years ago
and then i really want to spend time
focusing on on really new unpublished
work that we've been
looking at and trying to find new
mechanisms of really ultra rare diseases
and of one patients and the two patients
those kinds of cases
so
first our old example so in common
complex disease um
this is one of the first studies from my
lab we were trying to to figure out can
we identify some mechanisms for rare
disease
we teamed up with members of the
hypoglycemia and adverse pregnancy
outcomes consortium this is the hapo
consortium
and right around 2013 2012
they had just finished their first g was
and it was
this is for one measure of gestational
hyperglycemia this is basically a
indicator of diabetes that arises during
the third trimester of pregnancy
now uh the g wasp was super clean and
retrospective means it was super
underpowered um but there was one clear
lead hit that that was the largest
effect and even with follow-up studies
and much more uh elaborated populations
and more hits we we still know this is
what really one of the strongest um odds
ratio now you know we zoomed in on this
region this is sort of before
any kind of high throughput technologies
for um
for measuring gene regulatory element
activity and and before we really had
crispr technologies and so what a
student in my lab did was took you know
in this case a whole bunch of encode
data this is zooming in on that one
particular hit
um
manually cloned out in green a whole
bunch of regulatory elements actually
a whole bunch of regulatory elements
along the region along this region um
stuck them into luciferase reporter
assays basically a biochemical
assay where you can see if this element
has the ability to impact expression
from a promoter
and much to our
enthusiasm at the time we found many
many hits we found that lots of these
elements
that were identified with gypsy data dna
seek data for example do indeed have
regulatory activity in the region so we
we thought we were on to something
the question was what what gene are we
actually going to be looking at here the
gene in the region
hkdc1 at the time had
four or five this is all this is the
whole literature review on hkdc one at
the time there was very nothing
published on it um and the one really
exciting paper to us was this manuscript
down here looking at how this particular
gene evolved
and it showed that it was a
duplication event from a hexokinase gene
hk1 which is a little bit further down
in the genome
and this paper was proposing that this
might be
a new member of the hexokinase gene
family involved in glucose metabolism
fits perfectly with our phenotype the
problem
is
they're proposing a
hexokinase and if i looked at wikipedia
yesterday there's going to wikipedia
only four and this has been really well
established since the 70s uh very
careful studies eluding out
fractions from liver cells and so on
finding you know four clear peaks of
hexokinase activity um there's a group
of low km hexokinases one through three
and then uh glucokinase hexa pentas4
is the one that we think of that's most
involved with glucose metabolism
sorry dietary glucose metabolism um
and
we know that variation near some of
these other hexapennies has been
associated with
hyperglycemia and diabetes
uh
but you know but if there's not a fifth
one what is this hkdc1 gene doing and so
this is where we kind of took a bit of a
leap of faith the student in my lab
ended up
cloning out this gene purifying it
and showed that compared to hexokinase 1
it does actually have measurable
activity as a glucoconase or sorry it's
a hexakinase
the activity is a lot lower than
hexokinase 1
but is certainly still measurable and
then i think our real aha moment was we
started making a mouse model this is a
collaboration with brian leyden now at
uh university illinois chicago
where
we
made first of all we tried to make a
knockout for hkdc1 it was embryonic
lethal
and so we ended up propagating the
myosis heterozygotes and found
that their
only during pregnancy they demonstrated
basically an inability to process
glucose
at the correct rate sort of you know the
classic measurement that we would use to
to diagnose um hyperglycemia and
diabetes during pregnancy and so
basically what happened was across this
study we went you know and it took
several years about three years
across these publications we're still
working on understanding this today but
about three years we were able to go
from
this genetic association into gene
regulatory activity target gene
identification
and eventually a mouse model and i think
today this is the first mouse model of
gestational diabetes
so that's one example there's you know
many others i'm curing mercenaries
amazing work um working on the sortillin
gene and cholesterol and i you know i
was kind of going through all these and
figuring out you know what's the sort of
the key point where you're like okay you
really nailed it and you know and in
that case they're over expressing the
sortelling gene and mouse liver and
showing those impacts on on lipoprotein
uh distributions um there's some great
work from elena klosnenster
doing uh looking at the ftl locus as one
of the you know most prominent gwas
signal for obesity and linking it
not to
a gene in the region but actually to
distal
gene regulation distal regulation of a
couple of transcription factors irx3 and
rx5
and there's been a whole
bunch of work since then you know
linking these to obesity obesity
phenotypes and you know when these go on
there's you know examples of you know
insulin insulin secretion and so on and
in all of these cases
it seems to me or you know my my view is
that it's really once we get to these
kind of mouse models molecular studies
that's where the field starts to really
open up and lots of people can come in
and
and really nail down these mechanisms
so
um sort of these cases have in common i
mean they're all non-coding i mean
clearly
there's a huge burden of coding
variation and you know i'd say studying
that is is a lot more straightforward so
we're deliberately focusing on
non-coding regions but i think these all
demonstrate that there are paths forward
for all these non-coding variants um
you know i think what's been really
interesting is across all these studies
the ones that are getting figured out of
these really large effect size uh hits
and it kind of provocatively makes me
wonder if we should be funding you know
many many more low-powered g wasps
and many diverse you know gwas with
minimal populations because it's those
lead hits that are
the ones that are easiest to follow up
on the easiest to have impacts on um
but you know what really
kind of makes me somebody thinking about
over the past several years you know
i do a huge amount of functional studies
of gene regulation in my lab across
encode right
and i'm starting to really appreciate
how powerful they are as exploratory
data analysis but i'm also starting to
appreciate you know really how important
it is to get back into specific you know
molecular testing organismal testing to
really break through the mechanism you
know no matter how much data we can
accumulate in our exploratory studies um
you know i'll go through a couple
examples coming up it's it's sort of
it's these kinds of you know molecular
organismal testing that you need to
convince someone to develop a drug or
convince someone to to think about
changing patient treatment
so
you know playing on this theme of these
very large effect sizes we
you know started putting our heads
together and thinking well maybe we
should be thinking about you know the
biggest effect size as possible and can
we really you know drive up effect sizes
as a way to
discover more mechanisms of disease and
so that's when we started thinking about
turning to
rare disease studies this is in
collaboration with a whole bunch of
clinicians at duke and really around the
country
and in our conversations with them what
was really striking is you know i
naively went into these studies thinking
we've got mendelian genetics in
the textbook we know if you have you
know
if you have a recessive disease you have
to have your two hits and and uh and it
should be relatively straightforward and
what we kept finding and this varies
quite a bit across
classes of rare disease but you know dna
sequencing yields diagnoses uh in very
you know in a minority of cases and you
know certainly in some diseases it's
it's much higher um but in you know case
after case of studies we're talking to
clinicians they're saying well yeah
these patients clearly have a certain
disease we can look at their biochemical
look at their biochemistry look at
enzyme levels whatever it might be
and we can find one hip we cannot find
the other hand we can't find the genetic
cause that's that that fully explains
their disease and um in most of our
cases
so
one i'll tell a couple stories this is
one particular focus we've been working
on this is with priya kishnania duke
who's an expert on glycogen storage
diseases
and so we've been looking at a couple of
cases this is with greg crawford a
graduate student at yangar in the lab
looking at a couple cases of glycogen
storage disease type 9c so these are all
super ultra rare diseases gsd9 is
involved in enzyme deficiency for
phosphorylase kinase
it's autosomal recessive and
it involves a particular subunit of the
complex phkg2
so if you haven't thought about glycogen
metabolism since
undergraduate it's
you know this is our sort of first step
in processing glycogen into
and getting into glucose metabolic
pathways
phosphorylase kinase is is one of the
first steps in that process
and just showing here there's all sorts
of glycogen storage diseases involved
with different components of this
pathway well we're just looking at this
first one here
the
phkg2 is again it's a component of this
phosphorylase kinase complex and loss of
function
causes abnormal glycogen buildup in the
liver and um that leads to all sorts of
um issues i mean these kids i'll talk
about them a little bit are you know
they're they're
10 years old they're getting liver
cirrhosis it's really can be really
quite devastating um it's extremely rare
prevalence for the whole class of gsd9s
is something like 100 000 and then you
break it out into different subtypes
so you're talking about prevalences that
are pretty pretty hard to estimate
so i'll talk about two cases today this
is a pair of siblings um
one's nine-year-olds one's two
both have
fairly abysmal levels of
phosphorylase kinase activity from liver
biopsies
in both cases they have
one of the known causal variants
in the phkg2 gene
and in both cases
the second variant wasn't identified
after
genotyping and sequencing of the genes
so
um what we thought we would do is look
at gene expression of this of these
genes so
um
you know we didn't have um access to
liver cells at the time and so this is
just from whole blood cells actually we
went and ran rna-seq and one of the
first things we found
looking and this is really just a lot of
sequence steering um was evidence of
some sort of rna-seq signal
potentially what we now know to be as a
76 base pair pseudo exon
right in the middle of the gene and
actually just downstream of
one of the exons where there's known
pathogenicity so
um so this is interesting but we really
you know it wasn't really enough to
convince ourselves
um that this was actually contributing
to gsd nine and so what a poor very
younger in the lab did was say okay well
let's make a cell model can we make a
model of this patient so we started with
hex293t cells um we're using a crispr
cas9 genome editing strategy that
involves
driving homologous recombination via
a single stranded donor so you can
basically give the the donor sequence
as a single stranded
oligonucleotide and drive homologous
recombination um she derived single cell
clones um and just to give a sense of
how much of a pain it is she screened
you know over 500 clones um
found 80 or 79 with at least one of the
um what we think is the pathogenic
allele then proceeded to do stanger
sequencing you have to confirm um both
if you you know get homozygous editing
but you know with a lot of these um
crispr cast 9 strategy you can get
non-homologous and joining you can get
all sorts of indels and
and weird things going on we wanted to
exclude those as well um and so from
those 500 clones um
we ended up getting nine that were
useful for us seven homozygotes and two
heterozygous which is you know has
always been interesting to me usually
with crispr cast on you can you get sort
of an over abundance of homozygotes a
lot of times you either get editing or
you don't it's the heads that are hard
for us to get um
and so she went ahead and you know just
running simple gels sure enough in the
you know homozygous uh variant
pheno genotype this is um the genotype
that that we found in both of those kids
on that um because you can sort of do
genotyping while you're doing your
rna-seq um
you can you can sort of see you can
probably see it on the screens better
but there's clearly a band that
corresponds with you know what we think
is the pseudo-exon we've gone ahead and
sequenced it and sure enough it is
that's how we know it's 76 base pairs
you also see a loss of expression of the
phkg2 gene ostensibly
due to nonsense mediated decay and
because the 76 base pair exon creates a
frame shift
and and what was really convincing for
us is we then took these cells sent them
off to the the biochemistry lab at the
clinic
convinced them to spend a little bit of
resources running cell lines instead of
patient samples
and sure enough we see with this genome
editing model uh you know a massive
ninety percent reduction in phkg2 and
phosphorylase kinase activity which is
you know perfectly consistent with what
we we see in the patients and so you
know we think from this we're pretty
confident now that this um this intronic
variant is actually driving
disease on their second allele um
you know this is
you know there's one question of what we
can do with these patients knowing this
but it certainly is you know valuable
for families and i mean this is an ultra
rare allele in the population but it
does exist and you know we're trying to
push this to get this included into some
of the genetic screening now for um for
gsds
so that's probably our most that is our
most well-developed example but we have
others we're looking at gsd 3a this is a
another ultra rare glycogen storage
disease involved with um with a deeper
de-branching enzyme further down this
complex
you know here we had a frameshift
variant in in one on one allele a second
allele we didn't find anything from
genotyping um
it was actually here we went into
long read sequencing this is with
nanopore sequencing
and this was
incredibly helpful for us we found about
one and a half kilobase deletion
um in heterozygous in these patients
partially overlapping what's exon 23 of
the aglg and the branching enzyme gene
um we then went to using pac bio to do
long read rna sequencing
and sure enough is expected about half
of the transcripts from these patients
again this is just blood cells
is are missing the uh the agl
exon 23
um and you know we don't have as much
detail of a workup on this these this
patient yet but
it's pretty
should be pretty clear i think that from
what we can tell this exxon 23 deletion
would also cause a frame shift
and an nmd so we're still working to
validate that
so you know i think what's been um
really exciting for me about these
studies um you know first of all i to be
completely clear we went into these rare
disease studies i was looking for
regulatory elements i was like let's
find you know let's let's see what's in
there um we have yet to find any uh in
our studies of course very you know any
cases of regulatory elements that are
driving uh the patient phenotypes but
we're actually finding a lot of are
impacts on gene splicing whether it's
due to large deletions whether it's due
to
cryptic exon inclusion um and and it's
really making us think a lot more about
pathogenicity of splicing and uh in in
some of these rare diseases you know
here our exploratory analysis have
really relied on long-reed sequencing um
what's been really
striking to us though is how far we can
get using cell lines that are you know
not relevant to disease there's an
amazing amount of information we're able
to get by looking at blood cells
that allow us to infer what we think is
happening for example in the liver and
muscle of these patients
but again these are exploratory analyses
um you know when talking a lot with
clinicians you know just finding these
transcripts is not close to enough
information to
actually change how you might
treat or approach these patients or how
you might advise their families and so
you know we're really having to do a lot
of you know genome editing molecular
testing to to kind of break through to
mechanisms on that
so
let's see i've got maybe
five ten minutes left so so the question
then for us is you know how do we build
these pathways into highways and you
know we've we've as a field i think
figured out i don't know 100 maybe 200
mechanisms at most we've got 123 000 to
go um you know at the rate of
at the rate we're going we're falling
leave behind the the g-boss hits are
accumulating and the mechanisms are not
even coming close to the rate that we
need to keep pace um i think there's a
lot we can do
in some of these exploratory techniques
um i won't go into it in the sake of
time in too much detail but there's you
know there's a lot of effort across the
field to develop some high throughput
technologies for
actually figuring out if there are
non-coding uh variant effects on on gene
regulation gene expression um
you know i mentioned we use some
reporter assays and in some of that
hexokinase work um at the beginning of
my talk we use a system where you
basically take a regulatory element here
in blue you stick it in front of a gene
that glows like gfp or luciferase put
that into cells and if the cells glow
then you have good evidence of
regulatory activity
that doesn't scale very well to
large studies and so we've been using
a high throughput approach this is an
approach called starseek developed in
alexa stark's lab and
in 2013
and basically what you do is you take
your regulatory elements instead of
having them in front of the gene you put
them
in the three prime utr downstream of the
stop codon
um
and you don't clone a single element you
can put a library in here for example
this is a mixture of green and blue
elements
and we know that these elements in these
utrs
acting as enhancers can still control
regulation of a
activity of our promoter even though
it's upstream but what's really neat
about this system and i love about the
system is that
in doing so these elements are actually
driving expression of transcripts that
they're themselves embedded in other
ways they're they're really driving
their own transcription
and so
and because it's really you know
compared to looking at different colors
of gfps um you know it's a lot easier to
read out dna sequences we can do that
with basically rna sequencing for just
this utr region and you can start to
count up if you see
a lot of for example green elements near
here um in your expressed um transcripts
that's evidence that those green
elements are driving a lot of
transcription of themselves whereas some
other elements might be doing less
and long story short over over many many
years um our group and others um have
have really scaled this up to
the point where we can now assay you
know on the order of a billion different
fragments in a single assay somewhere
500 million to a billion
allowing us to cover the the human
genome at very high depth something like
you know 500 x coverage of the human
genome
and where we're taking this to try to to
drive genetic discovery of of mechanisms
of disease is
you know moving from single individuals
but actually now looking to do
population scale studies of human
regulatory activity
this is work from kerry strauss in the
lab where you know she's developed a
strategy to pool
limited number of genomes basically
increasing the amount of coverage you
can get
while at the same time
leaving you sensitivity to very rare and
personal variants which are most of
what's in there um
you know very briefly the way this works
is you you basically shear up the
genomes from these patients use you can
clone that in mass into these um
starseek backbones um you transfect into
cells this is acute diagram and the
reality is these are stacks of cells
that are grown in um you know either in
spinner flash or in these like large
multi-layer flasks to get enough cells
to do this so it's really limited to
cell lines i think at this point um at
least at this scale um and then we're
using very long 250 base pair of
paradigm sequencing to make sure that we
can
when we read out these elements that we
observe the genetics in between them
we're focused heavily on african
populations we really want to maximize
the amount of genetic diversity that we
can um that we can study and so
um and so we're you know most of our
samples at least going in uh in the
first couple hundred are all going to be
um african individuals
and we're working across other
consortium that are studying
basically these same populations to make
sure that our samples overlap with
with the work of others so we can share
information across
you know as expected most of the
variation that we're studying is rare
and very ultra rare
what's exciting for us is that we expect
that um at the coverage we have that we
will assay all of the common variants of
the human population and all of the like
low frequency variance in the human
population many many times over by you
know across these 300 individuals
and even rare variation we're going to
put a good dent in so we'll have
information for tons and tons of genetic
variation across the human population
um some of the initial data coming out
of these studies has been really clean
this is just a couple loci we like to
look at this is the beta globe on locus
and this is just three replicates of the
same pool of individuals
studied and you can see that
you know sure enough we're you know
we're lighting up like the hs2 enhancer
as you expect you can see the data is
really reproducible it's it's really
quite clean um and again these these
peaks now this it looks a lot like dna
seek or chipseek but
you know what it really is is you know
is is a is a quantitative measure of how
active these different regulatory
elements is and that's why you end up
tagging for example a subset of the dna
speaks show up as actually having
regulatory activity
and we look at the gottle1 locus a lot
again same idea that the signals are
very reproducible and you can tag a
subset of
dna's regions for example or you know
open chromatin regions is having a
strong regulatory activity um then up
here these are you know these are cis
regulatory elements um actually
predicted from um from xipping's group
and jill moore uh and henry over there
and uh and and we can see that there's a
strong enrichment for these kind of
orange and red um
candidates this regulatory elements
coming out of out of that in our in our
studies as well so
so far we've looked at around 10 million
genetic
variants assayed so far what's really
exciting is we need multiple variants
per regulatory element so we can start
to look at combinations and haplotypes
in some of these cases
the analytical components of this are a
huge challenge this is a bayesian model
that we published uh bill majoris
working with the group has published
to actually call where you do have
evidence of allele-specific regulatory
across these different alleles and just
a couple examples where you see you know
major skewing between reference and
alternate
across what goes in and what comes out
of these assays
i'll skip this in the interest of time
but you know i think that these high
throughput techniques for coming up with
you know effects of non-coding variances
are are becoming quite mature we're
trying to do this across huge
populations um in terms of identifying
target genes there's obviously a huge
amount of work that's going on in the
field developing crispr screens um you
know from our group at duke but also
jessie young grizz's group and many
others across the field i just wanted to
highlight one particular resource that
we we published last year where we
actually made a
crisper editing mouse
and you know basically just putting in
this case we don't we're doing our
crispr editing we often do what we call
epigenome editing we deliver
histone acetyl transferases for example
to activate histones we'll or crab
motifs to repress genes
and and delivering those into rows of 26
and we can you know bring these mouse up
and we can drive now um in vivo or or x
evocultured
cells from these primary cells from
these mice
we can drive genome editing or epigenome
editing in these cells
we've been using this system this is
part of our encode work
to look at aspects of immune cell
differentiation and primary mouse cd4
positive t cells um i'll just highlight
one quick slide from this this is
keystone a postdoc in the lab
where we can basically you know hit all
of the you know potential enhancers that
we think might be involved in th17
cell differentiation and we start to
differentiate these cells and ask where
do we we see effects on on key genes
that are involved in th17 cell activity
um and we're getting a whole bunch of of
interesting hits you know interestingly
a lot of these are are things that
already known like il-17 and ror gamma
but we're also finding um kind of stuck
in here some interesting new distal
regulatory elements um around for
example the bad f locus that we think
are contributing now to to t cell
differentiation and immune cell function
so
um
just to wrap up you know i think where
the challenges is moving forward is
coming up with cell and animal models
that can really support
these studies and really take us from
our exploratory analyses to our disease
mechanisms
there's
a lot of really cool approaches out
there i think the model organism
screening center from the udn the
indignance disease networks
is one great example where you can pair
model screening facilities model
organism screening facilities with rare
disease studies to try to drive
discovery of new genes
there's great examples of the saturated
saturation genome editing is taking
these crispr approaches and really
saturating whole loci the appeal of thaw
but the story of the bcl11a enhancer um
you know starting from you know
identifying the enhancer mutating it
turning it into a potential for therapy
and others gene editing therapies for
sickle cell disease that are using this
enhancer to try to um
to try to reactivate fetal globe and
compensate for sickle cell disease and
beta thalassemia
and the last thing i'll point out is
we're finding we're that we now have to
go back and get ipscs for all these
patients that that in the end um to
really get across this barrier what
we're doing is going to collect ipscs
we'll start to try to revert patient
phenotypes to genotypes to healthy
genotypes
and demonstrating effects there's sort
of a whole bunch of work here i think
this is kind of our i would predict one
of the bigger challenges that we're
going to face in the field
so i'll leave it there and thank my team
and you know there's been millions of
people involved and and generous funding
from from nih and others so
thank you and happy to take questions
um we've been thinking a lot about the
relatively low agreement between crispr
and pras and then also like animal
models where you do a reporter assay in
a mouse embryo for example um there have
been a few papers also on this recently
i was just curious to hear your thoughts
on that yeah we've been um
that's been one of the big thought one
of the big focuses of encode as well is
um
the not just there's disagreement
between
like the high throughput reporter
raspberries and the crispr screens and
there's disagreements in vivo as well um
you know i think in the
more transient assays we're able to
i think that just has to do with the dna
that you're putting in different you
know if you use assays as a kilobase
fragments versus 100 base pair fragments
um a lot of the difference seems to be
around sequence content we're trying to
develop methods to kind of
calibrate across these for example um
in terms of discrepancies on genome
editing um
yeah i think that's something that is
just a huge challenge and there's a lot
of off-target effects from some of these
things um i don't have a great insight
though yet on how to solve it
thanks yeah
yeah i guess we'll work on the rest of
the question at the break because we are
running today thanks again
[Music]